when I was a boy I had to choose path or
fate would choose for
me I've hurt people and I'm going to
hurt
more I'm asking forgiveness for what I'm
about to do
Savages gang wars this
city
crumbles
may we are the only ones we can
[Music]
trust betrayal that's not something that
I can
[Applause]
forgive
nothing about this brings me
joy you brought this on
yourself it hurts
me I have to kill
you Studios Echo all episode streaming
January 9th set your Disney Plus profile
to TV MA to stream viewer discretion is
advised
Amaya I see you I always
have tigers move in silence to catch
their
prey you are a tiger
Maya what what did you do Marvel Studios
Echo all episodes streaming January
9th